what is that what is good how you live
and how you feeling Sims how are you I'm
living good and feeling good I'm how
awesome that's good I hope you guys
enjoyed the pics pod yesterday today is
a little bit of something special we had
an opportunity of chimp Bailey coming in
the studio Anthes here you have had a
relationship with champ since Denver
yeah one of my favorite team is Denver
was your witch stop in the end of it was
my third stop it was bucks then to
Tennessee for a year to Denver for a
year and then back to Tennessee and what
stage of champ Bailey's career was he
when you were well he was getting
towards the end like he was no longer
one of the five best corners in football
but still dangerous and still like we
could trust him to play man-to-man on
Dez Bryant and people like that in big
situation so he was still really good
but no longer the best but like true
professional great guy like you could
see all the attributes that made him
special in his absolute prime yeah I
mean it's great technique oh great
technique great understanding of the
game as a whole and his ability to
redirect or like I've told you the
stories about how he'd scare me to scare
the crap out of me at practice right he
would stand between two receivers and
you thought neither of them were old I
would be like man I just can't get a
tell he would he was playing me instead
of usually where the quarterbacks
playing him we tried a high-low him in
practice left go sometimes and he'd be
leaned in one way but look in the other
and I just never like oh man okay let me
just move over to somebody else the hell
with that guy I mean that's what he was
Champ Bailey was unbelievable we talked
to him about his madden rating we talked
him about defending really good wide
receivers and which quarterbacks really
caused the most concern yep here it is
our special conversation with a legend
and possible hall-of-famer this year
yeah he's one of the semi-finalists
Champ Bailey the quarterback eyes we've
had a few secondary guys here Landon
Collins Jamal Adams they kind of shared
that staring contest with the
quarterback and you're trying to figure
it out is there one that pops to your
head right away of whether it's a Peyton
or a Brady or somebody that game where
they either got you or you got them
really good you know Phillip Rivers
we are those guys you always let you
know when he got you you know I hated
him for about two years great guy love
him to death right but he was just hard
to deal with you know because he would
you could tell he studied your
weaknesses because you know he would
find those moments when you just weren't
paying attention and he knew he couldn't
attack me to hold game but he had his
moments when he would just throw it in
there squeeze it in there and God was
accurate looks like it's floating but
it's not I feel like he would say
something too hey would ya yeah I got
you right there or he you know you come
back and you jump that one I'll do that
again or something a crazy like that
it's like half the time I don't know
what he's saying
yeah but I know he's just talking trash
and just you know he's the competitive
dude yeah and I appreciate it more now
than I did then you see and it's also
rare yeah quarterbacks don't show that
kind of camp know his he wears his heart
on his shoulder yeah you see Aaron
Rodgers do it a little you know I don't
think he does it much now but no but a
couple years ago you know the big I
haven't seen that lately the all right
so I got to bring up your Georgia
Bulldogs just real quick just this
weekend and I think it's kind of fair
that they're not in the Final Four
no no I don't I believe you can't have
two losses the way we lost and I mean we
lost to LSU yeah mmm yeah you could say
we should have won that game yeah we're
a better team but we didn't win yeah
okay we lost a Bama I feel like I feel
bad how do I think we're top 14 yes yes
but you understand them not understand
you got to win the games it doesn't
matter you know on paper we're better
than most teams but you gotta win the
game we're going to talk about Texas do
you say we yeah I say we yeah so I feel
like you guys say we about your college
teams but not about your pro teams oh
because that's family mmm pros business
mmm I never came nobody ever accepted me
as a family in the I don't say that like
what's your name I mean I spent 10 years
in Denver
yes but yeah I know
you know they still let me go you know
yeah you know I left Georgia because I
left they didn't kick me out you know I
left I was a junior and I left but
that's family I can always go back there
did you know it was a business before
the trade or after the trade really set
the tone from Washington today well I've
always known I've always known it was a
business it's just you don't really
understand it until you get a little
older you know you start seeing a lot of
your buddies get cut and little shady
things happen yeah I might have a bad
leg and he's back a week early but he's
out there running around because they
want to get that on tape you know those
little things you see and then you start
understanding it's not about if they
care about him or not it's about can we
say money get rid of him and that way
you love georgia more it made me
appreciate college football more right
now because it's interesting it's
different it's different you you played
with Deion Sanders in DC I mean you're
very laughs yeah yeah he did good thanks
for doing your research host but it's a
very similar style of play of course
athleticism all that what was that year
like with him like what did you learn
from him just being around him you know
it was not just him it's Darryl Greene
Johnson so I had him diagram my rookie
year the cap and then Deon comes in I
got okay to Hall of Famers they're
already Hall of Famers at that point
right yes right so I'm thinking okay you
know I got two guys I could learn from
first of all before he even got there
I'm worried if I'm gonna start but
everybody made it clear yeah you're
gonna start of course you're gonna start
I know we're gonna start but I'm
thinking like that these are two dudes I
look up to like how do I start over them
both of them but you know me and Deon in
starting and I just tried to pick their
brains and I mean it was a little
surreal having them out there but you
know when it was time to play it was
time to play and you know that's when I
really emerged I made my first Pro Bowl
that year and you know I got to give
them a lot of credit for well you know
how my career went different approach
either one of them that you found
interesting like yes of course
flamboyant and yet loud it seems like
way back yeah
more laid-back different styles but both
competitive is hell yeah too competitive
dudes just in a different way
I mean Dione was still a little
flamboyant at the time but especially
the way he dressed and carried himself
but their approach to the game very
professional I mean they always had
their plan technique they practice hard
you know they prepared I mean it was
yeah they were your typical pros and
their prime I would love to seen them
race all three you really that'd be a
tight one
oh I don't know yeah no I guess you do
the young me young me would have got him
was I 1 2 3 they're in their prime speed
how does that know man that's tough
because Darrell was a track guy yeah I
was a track good Darrell that was a
jumper and Dion was a sprinter as well
so that's hard I gotta say I gotta say
Darrell because he at least 1/2 you know
fastest man he once was man a few times
I give him there ok so then what about
you and Dean you know maybe we're
neck-and-neck you know I can't give him
anything were you like that was a
sodding mean to cut you off is like the
the the year you get traded like that's
kind of like unprecedented bit like
stuff at that time I'm a Rican right so
that's why that was the discussion
what's more valuable than hover 1,600
yards running back in football I mean
first of all in the end it was quick
Hortis he was the man you were the man
in DC okay and then we first thought
were you shocked that you were gonna
about to be traded no no because we had
some contract issues okay I was trying
to renegotiate my contract and that
didn't work out obviously
so they franchise to me now I could have
notified the whole trade just by not
saying that signing a franchise tag
right but they would trade me to Denver
you know we had the track record of
being a great football team make sure a
great franchise great owner of course
I'm going yeah and they were gonna pay
me what I wanted so it was a no-brainer
for me to sign their franchise and let
the trade go through yeah so you were
contemplating pulling Olevia of course
you know and it's one of those things
you know the thing about Libya
is he he would devalue himself if he
played he saw who went out of the game
last night right exactly
James Connor got hurt and every time
he's come back what did he do
get hurt right he's a running back
that's the toughest position on the
field physically look man they would
lose value if he played under one you do
so what is it like for you out of the
game with the intelligence about the
game watching people talk about the game
and then saying Levien's losing a ton of
money right now well they they don't
look at the big picture they're just
looking at this year okay yeah he
forfeited fourteen million dollars okay
but what did he forfeit it for the big
picture
okay the long-term deal the security
okay he goes out there he plays he gets
hurt three games and he misses seven
game maybe he comes back maybe he
doesn't who knows I mean it's so
unpredictable but one thing that is
predictable his values not going down
it's like playing the hole right he's
still worth just as much as Todd Gurley
or more so so why is that not a good
business move and why don't people talk
about who taught you the way to put it
who taught me I mean the business you
just forced me to learn you know just
experiences I wasn't sure if Deon was
explaining some stuff her you know that
of course those guys would tell you
things just as I told a lot of young
guys when I got older yeah but you don't
really understand until you go through
it and you feel it and you see your
buddies leaving and coming and going and
then you start the only experience can
really teach you anything
100% do you ever feel like you're
underappreciated as one of the all-time
great corners like III I'm not even a
lie I you are I'm just letting you know
you are yeah I'll answer that for you
but but I feel like you go overlooked in
the convo sometimes like I'll hear
people mention top five corners in the
last 20-30 years and you're almost like
the oh yeah and Champ Bailey yeah yeah
I've even made that mistake like well I
don't feel like you get the pub that a
Dion or a Darrelle Revis did or some of
those guys are Charles Woodson who
really didn't even play corner his whole
career yeah I don't know you know yeah
you get that I mean you got to give it
to them twelve
- intro trophy-winning right great Pro
yeah one of my idols er one of the best
athletes you ever seen you know double
sport guy you know I played with and
respect him to this day you know great
athlete I mean you can't really say
anything bad about him I mean he
performed yeah Revis I mean play New
York obviously visibility once you walk
in the door right great player when the
best ever do it that's one of the best
press man corners I ever seen right yeah
so you give them the credit because it's
do but I think that what the difference
is they had change success yeah and I
was never on the Super Bowl winning team
I was never on one of those great
defenses you think about right so the
fact that I didn't have that it kind of
takes away from what I did as a you know
from a personal level yeah
oh it is what it is you know I think
anybody who played the game or play with
me they put me in those conversations
it's just those guys that you know they
see a lot of other guys beating on their
chest about it I'm just not that guy
yeah and you're right though it's the
team it's the team that you never got to
play under the spotlight as much as
maybe some of those other guys yeah
exactly I think the the fascinating
thing is you're in the final 25 semi
finals for the Hall of Fame I mentioned
it before he better get in let's make
this thing happen it's the first time in
your life there you've made every team
you've made the all pros you've made the
Pro Bowls you've made the college you've
made the pros and now you're relying on
people that you've never met to sit in a
room and to all come to an agreement to
give you something that you can have for
the rest of your life yeah it's not your
hands and that's got to be a weird
feeling it is it's it is weird you know
it's hard to explain you know I you know
I talked to uh I try to reach out to
other Hall of Famers I talk to Jerome
Bettis recently and you know he wasn't a
first belly guy but he got in and
rightfully so so I'm just trying to ask
him about the process and he's just like
you know you just really can't sweat it
it's easier said than done especially
once you're in yeah but but it's lucky
like you said it my work is done and the
only time I really think about is when
you guys bring it up you know I try not
to even dwell on it because it's out of
my hands I can't do anything about it
I've done what I could do and hopefully
people respect it and give me the honor
of dessert so that's become the annoying
question that you get now yeah yeah but
it's it's a good problem to have
oh it's really Hall of Fame were these
stories Sims has shared a lot from his
career beautiful seven eight years of
NFL glory the poker games in Denver we
had fun
first of all none of us like to see
champ walk in the room when we playing
poker like we all know yeah yeah but
champs pockets were deeper than the rest
of us so you know that was the cheapest
guy he might have been the cheapest he
wasn't afraid to throw a little money
around every now and then too every now
yeah and I want to buy him out of this
pot I know he doesn't have a good buddy
out he had me yeah he had big big stacks
of cash people like myself that are fans
of the game it's those stories that we
love it's the stories about Jordan and
like the airplane aisle and like
dominoes or some crap but that that team
with Denver so who would be in these
poker rooms oh man Pam Brandon Marshall
Lamont Jordan Stokely Stokely Brandon
Stokley Dre blye who was tired Howard
and depending on the week right yeah we
yeah it was usually a Monday night
because in the NFL you had a Tuesday off
oh my god tight in oh shut up hundred
dollars in left town last time we played
really you're that I'm bringing that up
Tony should we go find happen he I want
$100 one night he oh I don't have the
money on me right now I'll bring by the
check in the next day or two with the
lines like three days later I never saw
again all right how was Sims as a poker
player how would you characterize him he
was good you know that wasn't a bad
poker player in the room everybody
understood it's just that LeMond Jordan
was bad I'm not including you know he
was he's just one of those guys he he'd
do the opposite of what you think he
should so I think he thrived in those
moments so he's on the river with a
seven - oh yeah raising yeah it's
nothing yeah he lost on the flop you
guys any pot Lamont was in you're in
yeah every now and then he'd have cards
though so you'd have to be scared
because you'd go man he might have to
seven but is this one of those weeks
where he's got three kings and you know
he rarely folded though rarely he do if
he folded he probably had to go to the
bathroom I mean s that's the type of guy
he was
man Stokely Stokely was the one we were
all Chinese he was a leprechaun he was
yes so this is Brandon Stokley and I
just in my head I'm picturing ring in
the slot with like Peyton Manning or
somebody but what was he like at the
poker did he he was like he said he's a
leprechaun I mean first of all I mean
he's eating a shamrock up his ass he
really did it didn't matter I mean he
called a Hail Mary against Cincinnati in
week one the ball in the air felt right
in his hand he ran first Rachel and win
the game that's genuinely believe that
Brandon Stokley is just a lucky luckiest
man alive definitely but but what else
is lucky he kind of creates his own look
he puts himself in position yeah that
lucky but things just seem to fall his
way if he rolls dice he'll ask for seven
and I'm telling you seven oh come on a
Stoke of luck it's unbelievable I mean
fight on the ravens of that defense
Manning touchdowns goes out to Denver I
mean yeah he's kicked he kicked got him
life I mean he's doing media things like
they had some competition who won
stokeley DJ Williams who won Stokely one
who else yeah those are good days are
good camaraderie moments at the ball a
lot of good times he told the story
recently when Nate was here about Randy
Moss sitting next to him on the plane
and like that oh crap moment
did you have any old crap moments with
any veterans like saying like damn this
is Randy Moss and he's gonna come sit
next to me like you know like oh my boy
even though I was in your eighth of my
NFL I believe it was Bruce Smith yeah I
played with him too that was if you are
old Dan Snyder what else said who are
the guys good at 92 let's get him in
here right no Bruce Smith came I mean
you talking about played in four Super
Bowls
all-time sack leader right not at the
time he was all tonight he was on his
way but we knew he was there to get
sacked know it just sitting he was a
Oh nonsense guy old grumpy veteran but
boy when we had those moments when we
were at work one of the coolest dudes
really I'm like I can't believe I'm
sitting here with Bruce Smith I remember
riding a limo to the club one night home
with Bruce Smith I'm like damn it's just
me and him you know and and throughout
my whole career
the guys are hung around the most weird
alignment for some reason you know I
guess because they like to eat I love to
eat yeah you know and they love to have
fun right he always says defensive
linemen are the most fun guys on the
team most fun guys always this is
automatic colt once once they could get
in that room they look at who their boys
are and they're good yeah and they're
set yeah just like that
Bruce Smith is enormous one one last
form because I know we're keeping you
forever the corners right now in the NFL
I think you got a bit of Mount Rushmore
but like who are the two or three that
just jump out to you right now where you
just go damn that's a special special
group oh man some good ones I could go
on and on I think one steady God has
been impressive as Patrick Peterson yeah
I mean to make the Pro Bowl every year
you've been in the league unbelievable
another guy we just talked about Byron
Jones yeah he's starting to stick out a
little more cuz I really focus on guys
who have that tough task of matching up
every week right that is a nightmare you
know and he does it and he's done well
Michael Thomas did nothing nothing
nothing right it's because I do to the
technician yes he is a technician and
another guy and you could say I'm biased
but I'm not Chris Harris you know and he
hurt his leg yesterday but that dude is
a technician and I watch him play he
plays with a lot of heart a lot of
confidence but his feet are never in a
bad place he's always in great position
somebody catch a ball on him he's right
there
right you know so those are the little
things I look at and those are three
guys that you know I would love to have
a month in yeah all right I got another
corner question Jalen Ramsey made so
much news with his willingness to talk
you talked about being on team with Deon
Diaw was another guy that was not afraid
to talk
you keep it close to the chest what is
it like to watch someone like jaylen
where you see all the talent and he's
taking a strategy that was the opposite
of what you were doing I appreciate it
because he's been himself you know I I
don't care nobody's like me nobody's
like him so I like guys to be themselves
and I love he was trying to be somebody
else then you know I wouldn't like that
but I think that's what he is he's
always been like that I hadn't seen
anything different so and he's bawling
so you know I I'm all for it dude did
you see what he did to luck yesterday
with the fake that fake yeah
luck luck was on the ground and Ramsey
went like this and luck went like this
he's like nope too slow a little and
they didn't throw the flag no maybe they
did that Devon Miller
bond did it two years ago and the same
thing and they threw a fight I think the
riff to be something going on there
because it was that was playful two guys
know each other right like they're
friends I also feel like Vaughn should
get no penalties ever ever because I
don't think Vaughn has a bone in his
body or he know I'm not that malicious
about anything he does he's just a dork
yeah he's like a good one to have fun
all the time you would dork Vaughn
sorry Vaughn thanks for the free socks
what do you got going on right now oh
well you know I'm I invested in this
company okay W health and basically they
make these sucks
laso sucks and what they do they mimic
ankle taping and one thing every athlete
hates is taping their ankles yes you
know so worse this is worse now don't
get me wrong I'm not just gonna throw a
pair of these socks on the athlete and
think that they're just not gonna take
their anger has it's a mental thing you
know all of us our brain wants to think
we need to tape our ankles right but
these things feel so good I wear them
every day got them on now I mean and for
old guy that doesn't run around anymore
I can only imagine if I was young and
playing what these would do for me I
mean they protect your ankles you know
they they have all the compression in
the right areas right they limit ankle
rolling by 75%
you want to know more about it lasso
gear.com tell you everything about the
sock back by technology great socks
lasso gear calm you got it yeah hey to
taking my ankles like I would have loved
this have something like
why'd you hey you know company I just
felt constricted I've never taped during
practice during the week because I was a
quarterback so I was like I don't need
to be in the game day they wanted you to
tape your agate and I would try my betta
toy it was mandatory I would try my best
to avoid wouldn't get tape either what I
was not doing crack it in practice I was
bad or I never take my I hated it
because it's not like you had on another
sock or two you know and it just didn't
feel right but with these socks they
feel like the regular sock but you could
tell the compression yeah in the support
you have right yeah unbelievable
yeah you're sweating yeah I think it's a
weight on my face thanks for coming by
great man I could talk to him forever I
know I know you got more stuff I do is
text me my own my last question would
just be what's it like to be a 99 in
Madden well I'm not anymore but well
when I was it was cool looks likes to
put in the game and go there cannot be a
rating better than this and I have that
rating it was amazing well first of all
the first time you see yourself on
Madden is amazing then it's like oh damn
I'm on there you know yeah you want to
play all the time then that gets old and
then you have everybody telling you how
good you are and you know you kind of
you know relish that moment then all of
a sudden people stop talking about it
what I mean your rating went down that
moment has to come right you know I was
just glad to live through that moment
cuz some guys they're ready to go down
and they're out of the league yeah at
least I kind of stole mine stays down
remember I think like the best I ever
got to was like 82 or 84 some of the
year I took the Bucs of the playoffs I
had one of those like an 85 think so
right right 80 boy I I just know that I
would do fit no way I was like I thought
you had like very good potential to get
I thought I was in 84 I couldn't be
wrong hey anybody out there just check
it out maybe I'm bullshitting throw the
challenge yes one throw the challenge
flag
yeah dude no man [ __ ] man
appreciate you hey hey good luck with
everything with the Hall of Fame oh man
you know it is what it is I was better
we were going in for this right here and
I stopped but I was watching you yours
Elise was good we've had a teaching the
more natural it did the more working on
it yeah yeah he went to Abington friends
so was the name is nicely bring this up
every time every time it have to bring
it up